now what's what's interesting is that
this group I mean Hulk Hogan was
probably one of the first big guys to
transcend in the movie yes right yes but
he got turned off by Hollywood yeah
apparently he got a couple of dick
grabbers I don't know the real story of
all the guys that I know and like I I'm
super supportive of Hulk because he was
super supportive of me it's a great guy
oh man and he right now you know he's
doing he finally got back they finally
brought him back in and w-w-which I was
super excited about because to me going
in the whole thing without Hulk being in
there was kind of like the video of me
interviewing Hulk Hogan for Spike TV I
got a chance to interview him for Spike
TV back in the day when he was Spike TV
went into the wrestling business sure a
little bit sure sure I was before I
helped that I help them do that cuz I
was one of the names at but yeah that's
why was Russell so for me as a kid I
mean I was a giant fan of Jimmy Superfly
Snuka and Bob Backlund when I was in
high school early 80s and Hulk Hogan's
so for me to get a chance to interview
Hulk Hogan it was sports and
entertainment huge personality the one
and only these guys are going to war out
here it's unbelievable now you finish
some ever made fights before you a you a
UFC Fan along a huge fan brush area now
I understand that you have recently
announced a partnership with TNA
Wrestling and it's president Dixie
Carter and you're gonna be moving to
Spike TV we're gonna see some Hulkamania
on Spike TV tell us
about that well you know brother tonight
I got a ton of energy and I'm partners
with Spike I'm partners with Dixie
Carter I'm partners with TNA and we just
got the green right brother
on January 4th take the impact we're
going wide open we're going ahead on
head we're going to battle WWE Monday
Night which annually for Hall coated in
TNA we're coming after everybody we're
coming out for everybody now I
understand that you have you recently
released a book if you've done a
wrestling tour in Australia when are we
gonna see Hulk Hogan wrestle in TNA well
brother I'm going January 4th like I
said Monday night we're going to war TNA
Impact but you never know I'm going over
there to take over the maniacs are
coming all the TNA stars gonna be there
and you never know when the old man with
the yellow boots might just step in that
ring brother Oh Hogan is coming back
ladies and gentlemen TNA Wrestling live
on Spike TV hugs here for the fights do
brother runs wild on you you had a
jidoka would spot brother I was so happy
you ever bet Gene Okerlund now oh yeah
what a nice guys on the planet but the
Hulk I mean when I got to do my stuff
with him cuz we not only did the Malone
stuff y'all would mean Rock mean mean
Malone against Rodman and Hogan but the
next month they come in and because we
shot that angle on The Tonight Show and
the next month they go in Hogan and
Bischoff and they run J off the set I
come in from the wings that Hulk on his
ass and it's me and Jay Leno
it's heads oh that is so funny Jay Leno
was holding the Hulk down he grabs
[Applause]
this is so ridiculous
God it was but you know it was so much
fun good I'll tell you you know what oh
yeah another guy I mean he came and
worked out with us and he didn't didn't
spend as much time like Malone day
because Malone's like a super athlete
but I think J works out at all no turns
wrenches well gotta learn yeah I've got
to learn how to move around a little bit
and yeah we just were trying and Hulk
was never that guy to lay stuff out like
today a lot of this stuff is laid out
you know back then it was like you
called as you go and write and so I was
a guy who actually did that I could lay
everything out and that's how I like to
know where we're going and I'm still
gonna talking the whole time you know
but you know bottom line is uh you know
J just working him through it and it was
a lot of fun well when Hulk Hogan was in
Rocky 3 I mean that was you that was
[ __ ] fantasy and then you you also got
to see how goddamn big he is when he
picks sly up by his neck right like holy
[ __ ] and then you know when they go
through the whole thing went after it
you know Hulk is like smiling and laugh
with them and so alright like what it is
brother why are the greatest moments
ever young it was a great moment in my
awesome I mean it was that was a big
moment in film too for a lot of people
that thought like pro wrestling is fake
right it's like well ain't nothing fake
about that I mean it's entertainment but
if you don't think that's [ __ ]
difficult to do like look at the size
dance Jesus go keywords million bucks
there he look fantastic